W REPORTING ON
THFECT ON THE BLICANAEL WARREN S
AMBITION.
OUR PANEIS BAC
IT'S GREATEP
YOU'RE THEE U'RE OUT OF POWER.S.
YOIRING STAFF ANPANDING YOUR OP
E EARLY ST DONALD
TRUMP HADE QUITE CLEAR MIKE
THEY'RE LKINABE  T
PRESIDENT
I CANNOT BLOCK THEION
RESULTS OR CERTIFYING THE
EC, S.
HOW DOES A NOT FRIEND OF TRUMP
>>T'A ICINT MIKE PENCE
BUT ALL BLS WH TO
RUN IN 2024.
HAVE MUCELATIONSHIP AT ALL RIGHE
HER M TOLD BTWO
REPUBLICANS IN FIVE MONTHSNCE AA
DOHIS FO VICE PRESIDENT AND SAI
BUATS
EXPANSION OF HIS POLICM
ALL THISSIC
COUNY, VISITAND SOUTH CAROLINA A
THIS EFFORT E MIKE
PENCE IS NOT TRYING TO PATCH
PR GOINGBES TH THE
NT OF ALL
I E TO
MIKE PCE EARLIER THIS .
THAT N THWARTED Y  CTO SERVE?
BY MWOMAN.N INFEELS CALLEDO
DOHIS, IT'S NOG TO BE
UESTION.ME ARE EVESAP E ,  HAPP
MIKE PENCE IS TAKING
ELP ME.
WHAT'S L LANE INGTON WHITE HOUSE
NOW E
MIKE, IF YOU TAKE TRP
ION,L
SAYS YOU'RE TRR CAE T TRUMP
YOU WOULDN'T SUPPORT THE BIG
LIE.
>> I THINK TSTION IS
LIT
IF YOU LOOK AT IOWW HAMPSHIRE A
EPLI.
MODERATE REPUBLICANSY
AREN'T INTERESAND
EVLIA LOT OF ONS RINOW.
I E POMPEO IN IOWA
YOU'VEIVITY
PEE L CY.R'S
THRO FRONTAIN OFD HE COULD
THIS IS PENCE A COUPLE MONS
O HE WITH E
>> WAS A DARY INOF THE UTE
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND I HAVE
SPOKEN MANY TIMESINCE WEEF
OFFICE.
AND I DON'T KNOW I'LL EVEREYN T
EYE ON AP SAYSS . GUESS THINK W
HE SAYTHE RIGHO GET BACK IN PRED
AC
YON DOESN'T SA HE'
CRITICAL OTHEI ON
ANDLAYING, YEAH, W
DAY, BUT  AT T STUFF WE
TOGETHER.
REPUBLIC THAS OT
SAME
PREN
BUT TH CAN'TID IT,
TRUMP WANTS
ONE HE HE DOESN'T FEELHAT FELLOO
NOT YOUR>>, HERE'SHAVE
TOE.
I AN'T STH
AMBI-
REPUICYES..
THE BULK OF TH
ITH AGAIN, THINGS CAN BUT IF YO
GOING TOA AND NEW HAMPSHIR0 DEHE
H CONSEQUENCE.
>> TISOF LIKAT
IN THE LAST
OCARTYES
PERSONALITIES AND CARET
WHO IT I
PARTY, NOT WHAT IT IS THY OI.
PENCE'S ENT HE M AE  WE
HAT'S LIKE LOOK AT THE .S LOOKIC
RIT NOW. CE D BE
RO, F
HE OBAMA-TYPFIGURE HAVE TO
>>WANTP, SHED TRUM
AILABLE TO THEAR